INTERVIEWER 1: If I told you
about a place where mud boils,
water explodes from the ground,
and bearded, horned beasts
walk across steaming red lakes.
You'd think I was crazy.
But I promise you,
this is a real place.
The man who dared to visit this
ominous hellscape was this guy.
JONO HEY: Hi, my
name is Jono Hey.
I'm a designer living in London.
We were actually on a
road trip at the time.
[INAUDIBLE] from Nevada and
Idaho from San Francisco
to Yellowstone itself and to
the neighboring Grand Tetons.
And then down through Utah,
to Bryce Canyon National
Park, Zion National Park, and
then back through Yosemite.
INTERVIEWER 1: This picture
is of Grand Prismatic
Spring in Yellowstone.
And, OK, it's not the ominous
hellscape I made it out to be.
Yellowstone is visited by 3 and
1/2 million people every year.
And it's actually the oldest
national park in the country.
JONO HEY: Grand
Prismatic Spring is
one of the most beautiful
and otherworldly sites
on the planet.
It just looks spectacular,
like a giant eye.
It's essentially a boiling
lake with just a rainbow
of colors from all the
bacteria in it that color it.
From this beautiful blue
water in the middle,
to this bright oranges
and reds on the outsides.
INTERVIEWER 1: And this
shot wasn't easy to get.
With outdoor photography there
are a lot of different elements
to deal with.
From both the nature around
you, and your own technology.
JONO HEY: I remember when
we arrived at the site.
We could see
something in the mist.
These dark shapes.
So you sort of
follow the boardwalk.
And I remember, sort of, saw
these shadows in the mist.
And we started
hurrying towards them.
Yet you had this
joint feeling of like,
this is really exciting
and these are Bison,
and Bison are really scary.
And I remember as we
got closer to them,
and started to try and
take some photos it
was a constant battle.
There was the spring
clean-up steam all the time.
And my wife was there
with a len's cloth,
wiping the front of the
lens as I would take a few,
and then it would steam up.
But despite all that, we
did still come away managing
to get this picture of
this incredible moment.
INTERVIEWER 1: It's a picture
that perfectly sums up
why Yellowstone is so popular.
Vibrant colors, the wild
animals, and the alien feel
of the landscape, makes it
one of the most unique places
on earth.
JONO HEY: It was an
awesome combination
in the true sense of the word.
INTERVIEWER 1: Hey guys,
if you like this video,
check out this next
one on some of the most
bizarre roadside
attractions across America.
INTERVIEWER 2: Attractions,
or road side distractions,
as I like to call them.
I've been visiting them again
as long as I can remember,
but this one is
really a highlight
because of its obscurity.
INTERVIEWER 1: Thanks for
watching and as always,
please subscribe.